bon la violence de ce tremblement de
terre a provoqué des dégâts
considérables des infrastructures
touchées des usines et des raffineries
en feu de nombreux axes routiers vous
l'avez entendu sont totalement
impraticable les transports ferroviaires
maritimes et aériens ont été suspendus
fanny stener quelques minutes la vague
déferle sur les pistes de l'aéroport de
sendaï au milieu des flots un groupe de
personnes piégées sur le toit de ce
bâtiment juste à côté de la tour de
contrôle quelques minutes plus tard les
voici comme sur le pont d'un bateau dans
cette région industrielle des milliers
d'infrastructures ont été submergées en
un ensemble
un départ de feu a été signalé dans une
centrale nucléaire mais pour l'heure les
autorités n'ont détecté aucune fuite
radioactive au total une dizaine de
réacteurs se sont automatiquement
arrêtées dans tout le pays
dans le port de sendai les navires
s'entrechoquent comme des bouchons dans
une mer déchaînée à 380 km au sud dans
la baie de tokyo
cette raffinerie a été touché de plein
fouet par l'ondé de choc les flammes
dévorent les cuves de stockage un
brasier gigantesque
le séisme n'a pas non plus épargné les
routes ici
cette double voie des coupes et comme
avec une lame le goudron et transformé
en un ruban ondulant à tokyo les
gratte-ciel ont tangué pendant plusieurs
secondes malgré les normes antisismiques
avec lesquels ils sont construits des
incendies se déclarent à peu partout
dans la capitale japonaise
près de quatre millions de personnes
sont plongés dans le noir
sept heures après le séisme
les dégâts semblent donc colossaux mais
il faudra encore longtemps aux japonais
pour en mesurer l'ampleur exacte